toutes les bonnes équipes sont les bienvenues sur le
terrain de Quidditch
qui semble une blague
mentir rire et toi Billy
non ça me rappelle une petite fille d'
une ville de l'acier qui avait le rêve de danser
le pont était empilé contre Alex tu
sais comment elle a surmonté ces chances  en
croyant en elle-même et en essayant, elle a
littéralement dû devenir une maniaque, elle a dû
se déshabiller, elle a dû s'asseoir
l'année prochaine et se cambrer et elle a
tiré la chaîne vers nulle part et s'est
aspergée d'eau,
il a pris sa chair depuis le film de
les années 80 ouais tu as sacrément raison
je crois si fort qu'elle a tourné oh et elle a
tourné et elle a tourné et elle a tourné et elle s'est
tournée dans cette école de danse et
elle s'est tournée dans nos cœurs maintenant dans
la seconde moitié de quoi que ce soit l'enfer  vous les
gars appelez ce jeu, mettons nos jambières
et dansons nos culs,
entrez ici, adorables maniaques